OK, so it's a big crowded singles bar. One regular described it as the place you go at the end of the night when they play old hip hop and R&B that everybody knows the words to.
好的，这是一个拥挤的大型单身酒吧。一位常客形容它是深夜去的地方，那里会播放大家都耳熟能详的老派嘻哈和R&B音乐。
People are grinding up on each other like it's a high school dance, like it is just shameless and fun and a little sloppy. And it's a meat market. I like it because it's shameless. Someone will always hit on you. That's like, why I come here.
人们像在高中舞会上那样互相磨蹭，简直毫无廉耻，既有趣又有点随意。这就是一个猎艳场所。我喜欢它，因为它不知羞耻。总会有人搭讪你。这就是我来这儿的原因。
So, lots of pick ups, lots of ghosting afterwards. It's early evening and that's what I'm here to look for-- serial ghosters, people who kiss and disappear, which are not hard to find at all. And yes, some of them definitely agreed, ghosting is bad. They felt guilty, like this woman. She ghosted a guy after seeing him for two months. Great guy, she said. Hit it off immediately. Saw each other a couple nights a week.
所以，有很多搭讪，事后有很多消失。现在是傍晚，我来这里正是为了寻找这些人——那些频繁消失的人，那些亲热完就消失的人，这在酒吧一点也不难找。是的，他们中有些人确实承认，玩消失是不对的。他们感到内疚，就像这位女士一样。她和一个男人约会了两个月后就玩了消失。她说，他是个好人。两人一见钟情。每周见几次面。
And then I went to a wedding, met another guy that I was very into.
然后我去参加了一个婚礼，遇到了另一个我非常心仪的男人。
First guy kept reaching out, texting.
第一个男人一直联系我，发短信。
And I just wasn't responding as quickly or as often and we weren't making plans. And he said, I wonder if I'll ever see you again. And that-- I didn't respond to that. I feel really bad about it. I feel really, really bad about it still. But he's a great guy, he did nothing wrong. A great guy and I feel bad for ghosting him.
而我回复得没那么快、也没那么频繁，我们也没有再约见面。他说：“不知道我还能不能再见到你。”对此——我没有回复。我对此感到非常内疚。我至今仍然感到非常、非常内疚。但他是个好人，他没做错什么。他是个好人，我为对他玩消失感到难过。
There are so many reasons to ghost. This guy for instance, has a boyfriend. He's there at his table. They're in an open relationship. And basically, he got drinks with another guy, one he met on Grindr. And it was fun. It was kind of romantic.
玩消失的原因有很多。比如这个人，他有男朋友。他就坐在那边的桌子旁。他们是开放式关系。基本上，他和其他男人喝了酒，是在Grindr上认识的。过程很有趣。还有点浪漫。
I should have disclosed that I have a boyfriend, but I didn't. I think I perceived him kind of to be more monogamous. There was kind of a point where he was talking about, like, gay guys who sleep around too much.
我本该坦白我有男朋友，但我没有。我觉得我当时认为他更倾向于一夫一妻制。有那么一刻，他还在谈论那些私生活过于混乱的男同性恋者。
So he said nothing about his boyfriend and the open relationship. They kissed when they say goodbye. And, knowing he messed up, he ghosted the guy-- his first ghost, he says.
所以他对他男朋友和开放式关系只字未提。他们告别时接了吻。他知道自己搞砸了，于是他对那个男人玩了消失——他说这是他第一次玩消失。
So this, for me, is weird. And it is like a vortex of feelings, absolutely. It is like, why did I do that? I feel guilty about it. You're not--
所以，这对我来说很奇怪。这绝对是一个情感漩涡。就像是，我为什么要那样做？我为此感到内疚。你不是——
Shame.
羞耻感。
I mean, shame, yes. Yeah.
我是说，羞耻感，是的。没错。
Some of the ghosting I heard about, it made me wonder about the correct usage of the word ghosting. Like, OK, what if you've dated somebody for years but it's on and off, and they're your drug dealer. And you're in college.
我听到的一些关于玩消失的案例，让我质疑“玩消失”这个词的正确用法。比如，如果你和某人约会多年，但分分合合，而他们还是你的毒贩。而且你还在上大学。
And then he was just like, listen, I feel like you're only in it for the weed. And I was like, no! Not at all. And then he stopped getting me weed and--
然后他只是说：“听着，我觉得你只是为了大麻才跟我在一起。”我就说：“不！完全不是。”然后他就不再给我提供大麻了，而且——
As a test to you, to see if you really cared about him?
作为一个对你的考验，看看你是否真的在乎他？
Yeah.
是的。
And were you were only in it for the weed?
那你当时真的只是为了大麻才跟他在一起吗？
(silence)
（沉默）
OK, that pause gives you the whole answer, right? The answer is yes. And she cut him off.
好的，那阵沉默给了你全部答案，对吧？答案是肯定的。于是她甩了他。
Why not just tell him? Why not just be direct?
为什么不直接告诉他？为什么不直接一点？
Because I was afraid that if I was honest, like, then I wouldn't be able to get weed at all. I sound like I have a problem here. But--
因为我害怕如果我说了实话，我就根本买不到大麻了。听起来我好像有问题。但是——
Are you high right now?
你现在吸了吗？
No, I'm not. I'm not, I promise.
没有，我没有。我真的没有，我保证。
That was just a joke.
那只是个玩笑。
OK. No, I'm not. I promise I'm not.
好的。不，我没有。我保证我没有。
She feels bad about ghosting him, but you know what? Ghost a few more people, apparently you can get over that. This woman, Carrie, was at a table with friends celebrating somebody's birthday. She told me that she's ghosted five or six people. Like anything else, you get used to it as you watch them flailing in your texts like fish thrashing around on the deck of the boat, gasping, desperate.
她为对他玩消失感到难过，但你知道吗？多玩几次消失，显然你就能克服那种感觉了。这位女士，卡丽，正和朋友在一张桌子旁庆祝某人的生日。她告诉我她已经对五六个人玩过消失了。就像其他事情一样，当你看着他们在你的短信里像被甩在甲板上濒死挣扎的鱼一样扑腾、喘气、绝望时，你就习惯了。
A couple of them would just text me like every couple of days with like a question mark. But then they just realized what was happening. And then one of them tried to reach out to me on LinkedIn.
他们中的几个人会每隔几天就给我发短信，带个问号。但后来他们意识到发生了什么。然后其中一个人甚至尝试在领英（LinkedIn）上联系我。
OK, not what LinkedIn is for. But her friends around the table are all like, oh yeah, that's happened to lots of people.
好的，领英可不是干这个用的。但桌子旁的朋友们都说，哦，是的，很多人都遇到过这种情况。
Some men apparently think that LinkedIn is the way in.
显然有些男人认为领英是切入点。
She felt like, explaining to these guys exactly why she did not want to see them-- people had done that to her and it felt terrible. It just seemed less cruel to ghost. A real estate guy named Jason had a slightly different way of looking at this. He sees ghosting as tactical, like he only ghosts rare, special circumstances when it is called for. Case example, very recently a woman on the subway asked him the title of a book that he was reading. They got to talking.
她觉得，向这些男人解释她为什么不想见他们——别人也曾这样对她，感觉糟透了。玩消失似乎没那么残忍。一位名叫杰森的房地产经纪人对此有不同的看法。他认为玩消失是一种战术，他只在罕见、特殊的情况下才会玩消失。举个例子，最近在地铁上，一个女人问他正在读的书的书名。他们聊了起来。
She was really attractive. She thought I was attractive. And then before she gets off the train she goes, we should exchange numbers. And I go, all right, yeah, let's exchange numbers. Yeah, sure. I mean, yeah, I'll take you out sometime.
她非常有魅力。她觉得我也很有魅力。然后她在下车前说：“我们应该交换电话号码。”我就说：“好吧，行，我们交换号码。没问题。是的，我会找时间约你出来的。”
Wait, you got picked up on the train?
等等，你在地铁上被搭讪了？
Yes. It's not strange. It happens to me all the time.
是的。这并不奇怪。我经常遇到这种情况。
I'll say for the radio audience, you're very good looking.
我得跟广播听众说一下，你长得非常帅。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Anyway, they go for drinks. At first it's all normal. And then--
总之，他们去喝酒了。起初一切都很正常。然后——
This was the first red flag. She said the second I got off the train, I called my sister and told her about you. I was like, are you really close with your sister? And she's like, yeah, we talk every day. And I'm like, oh, OK, that's kind of cool.
这是第一个危险信号。她说：“我下地铁的瞬间，就给我姐姐打电话说了你的事。”我问：“你和你姐姐关系非常亲密吗？”她说：“是的，我们每天都聊天。”我说：“哦，好吧，那还挺酷的。”
Then she was like, yeah, then I told my brother about you. And I go, what? So, this is the turning point of the drinks. This is where I stopped ordering drinks, because we were two drinks in and she starts telling me about her pet rats. OK?
然后她说：“是的，然后我告诉了我哥哥关于你的事。”我说：“什么？”所以，这是喝酒时的转折点。也就是在这个时候，我停止点酒了，因为我们才喝了两杯，她就开始跟我讲她的宠物鼠。明白吗？
She has three pet rats that have cages, but they sleep in her bed and they chew through her sheets once a week. So she has to buy new sheets once a week. And I go, wait, are-- what are you? I'm sorry, rats? She's like, yeah, they're so cute but they chew through my sheets. And I go, OK.
她有三只宠物鼠，有笼子，但它们睡在她的床上，每周都要咬烂她的床单。所以她每周都得买新床单。我说：“等等，你是……什么？对不起，老鼠？”她说：“是的，它们很可爱，但它们咬烂了我的床单。”我说：“好的。”
She goes to the bathroom and he asks for the check while she's gone, walks her to the bus.
她去洗手间时他结了账，并把她送到公交车站。
Because she was taking the bus uptown even though the train was a block away, another red flag. Waited for the bus with her, never spoke to her again. She sent text messages, she's called, I have never responded again. There is no way I am doing anything with the rat lady, not happening.
因为尽管火车站就在一个街区外，她还是选择坐公交车去上城区，这是另一个危险信号。陪她等了公交车后，我就再也没跟她说过话。她发过短信，打过电话，但我再也没有回复过。我不可能会跟那个鼠女有什么瓜葛，不可能发生。
If somebody seems too out there, he says, if they seem like they are beyond reasoning with, he ghosts. He does not see this as cowardice. He sees it as standing up for himself. These unrepentant ghosters, sometimes talking to them felt like talking to hardened commandos, you know? Fresh off some battlefield who have learned that feelings are not always helpful.
他说，如果某人看起来太不可理喻，如果他们看起来超出了沟通的范畴，他就会玩消失。他不认为这是懦弱。他认为这是为了保护自己。这些毫无悔意的“消失者”，有时与他们交谈感觉就像在与久经沙场的指挥官交谈，你知道吗？刚从战场上下来，已经学会了感情并不总是有用的。
I would describe my dating life as a series of infrequent one night stands.
我会把我的约会生活描述为一系列罕见的一夜情。
This woman said that after one Tinder date, you go home with somebody, you don't owe them anything. She ghosts unapologetically.
这位女士说，在一次Tinder约会后，你和某人回家了，你并不亏欠他们什么。她玩消失时毫无愧疚。
And if you're going to dwell on this date that happened and be like, well, why didn't she text me back? Why didn't I get a reason? Why did I do wrong? You're just overthinking it. I don't want to get into answering all their questions and making them feel better about themselves or giving them feedback, you know?
如果你要纠结于这次已经发生的约会，想说“好吧，她为什么不回我短信？为什么我没得到个理由？我做错了什么？”，那只是想得太多了。我不想陷入回答他们所有问题的泥潭，也不想让他们自我感觉更好，或者给他们提供反馈，你懂吗？
Do you feel like you're being a coward or you're being practical?
你觉得你是在当懦夫，还是在表现得很务实？
Can both be an answer? I would say both.
能两者兼顾吗？我会说两者都是。
I love that she says that. I find her to be completely convincing in every way, and also a coward. She wants to avoid confrontation. We all tell ourselves all kinds of things to avoid confrontation, and we can be very convincing-- you know, with ourselves. It's so much easier to never say anything, to never dig in our heels, to never say the truth. That's why it's so popular. Today in our show, we have stories of people, for a change, summoning the courage, getting it together, the spineless getting a spine. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我喜欢她的这种说法。我觉得她说的完全令人信服，但同时也是个懦夫。她想逃避冲突。我们都告诉自己各种各样的理由来逃避冲突，而且我们可以表现得很有说服力——你知道，是对我们自己。什么都不说，从不坚持己见，从不说出真相，要容易得多。这就是为什么它如此普遍。今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲一些人终于鼓起勇气、振作起来的故事，让那些没骨气的人长出骨头。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, Finally. So we start dealing with somebody getting up the nerve to do something that really, it would be nice to see more often. He makes an apology. And not just any apology. Nancy Updike has a story about the anatomy of this one particular and unusual instance of "I'm sorry." Quick warning if you're listening to our podcast, we've unbeeped a few curse words here in the internet version of today's show. If you want a beeped version, it is at our website. Here's Nancy.
第一幕，终于。所以我们开始讲一个人鼓起勇气去做一件确实值得多见几次的事。他道歉了。不仅仅是普通的道歉。南希·厄普代克有一个关于这次特别且不同寻常的“对不起”的解剖故事。如果你正在收听我们的播客，先提醒一下，我们在今天节目的互联网版本中去掉了某些脏话的哔哔声。如果你想要带有哔哔声的版本，可以在我们的网站上找到。这是南希。
I read about this apology at the time it happened, but I never listened to it until recently. I listened in headphones on the subway and it was the auditory equivalent of seeing a snow leopard stroll through the subway car. This apology was about sexual harassment-- another one about sexual harassment-- but it was startling because it was not curt or vague. It was not a lawyered up mess of non-contrition in the passive voice. It was a true reckoning, publicly and fully accepted by the person who'd been wronged.
我曾在事情发生时读到过这个道歉，但直到最近才去听。我在地铁上戴着耳机听，那听觉效果相当于在地铁车厢里看到一只雪豹在漫步。这次道歉是关于性骚扰的——又是关于性骚扰的——但它令人震惊，因为它既不唐突也不含糊。它不是一份律师起草的、被动语态的毫无悔意的混乱文件。这是一次真正的清算，并被受害者公开且完全接受。
She forgave him. That almost never happens-- a public apology that lands. And everything that went into this apology, which is a lot, is an answer, one answer, to a question that keeps wafting up from stories about sexual harassment in the last couple of years. The question of, what are men supposed to do? What are they supposed to say?
她原谅了他。这几乎从未发生过——一次奏效的公开道歉。而这次道歉所包含的一切——内容非常多——是对过去几年中围绕性骚扰报道不断涌现的问题的一个回答。这个问题就是：男人应该做什么？他们应该说什么？
I'm not talking about situations where a man denies anything happened. I'm talking about the ones where they've agreed that something did happen, something bad. But, what do they have to say to be forgiven, to move on? Let's start at the end, with the apology. Then we'll hear from the people involved.
我指的不是男人否认发生过任何事情的情况。我指的是那些他们已经承认发生过某种事情——某种糟糕事情的情况。但是，他们必须说些什么才能被原谅，才能继续前进呢？让我们从结尾，从道歉开始。然后我们会听到当事人讲述。
The person who's apologizing is a writer, also actor and many other things, named Dan Harmon. He co-created the TV show Rick and Morty, and also an NBC comedy called Community about a group of adults going to community college. Dan was the creator and showrunner of Community. He had a bunch of writers who worked with him on the show but he was the boss, essentially.
道歉的人是一位作家，也是演员和其他很多身份，名叫丹·哈蒙。他是电视剧《瑞克和莫蒂》的联合创作者，也是NBC喜剧《废柴联盟》的创作者，该剧讲述了一群成年人在社区大学的故事。丹是《废柴联盟》的创作者和剧集主管。他有一群编剧和他一起工作，但他本质上是老板。
The thing he's apologizing for happened there. Dan delivered his apology last year, in 2018, on his podcast, Harmontown. I'm going to play most of it for you-- seven and a half minutes of it-- which is short if you're getting a foot massage but long for a public apology.
他道歉的事情就发生在那里。丹去年，即2018年，在他的播客《哈蒙镇》（Harmontown）中表达了歉意。我将为你播放其中的大部分内容——七分半钟——如果你正在做足疗，这很短，但对于公开道歉来说很长。
It-- in 2000 whatever whatever, I can't remember, 2009, 2006, 2000 something something, I had the privilege of running a network sitcom. And I-- I was attracted to a employee. I really want to be careful about that language. I think a huge part of the problem is a culture of feeling things that you think are unique and significant because they're happening to you, and saying things like, I had feelings for, and I-- I fell for, and all these things. I mean, the most clinical way I can put it in fessing up to my crimes is that I was attracted to a writer that I had power over because I was a showrunner.
那是……在2000年无论哪一年，我不记得了，2009年、2006年、2000年什么的，我有幸执导了一部网络情景喜剧。而且我……我对一名员工产生了吸引力。我真的想在这个用词上小心谨慎。我认为问题很大一部分在于一种文化，即当你产生一些你认为独特且重要的感觉时，仅仅因为它们发生在你身上，你就说出类似“我对他有感觉”，“我坠入爱河了”之类的话。我的意思是，在我坦白罪行时，我能说出的最临床的表述是，我被一名我在职权上管辖的编剧吸引了，因为我是剧集主管。
And I knew enough to know that these feelings were bad news. And so I did the cowardly, easiest, laziest thing you could do with feelings like that and I didn't deal with them. And in not dealing with them I made everybody else deal with them, especially her. Flirty, creepy, everything other than overt enough to constitute betraying your live-in girlfriend to whom you're going home every night, who is actually smart enough and respectful enough to ask you, do you have feelings for that young writer that you're talking about, that you're paying all this attention to? And saying to her, no, because the trick is if you lie to yourself you can lie to everybody. It's really easy.
我知道这些感觉是不祥之兆。所以我做了这种感觉下最懦弱、最简单、最懒惰的事情，我没有去处理它们。而且因为没有处理它们，我让其他人去处理它们，尤其是她。调情、令人毛骨悚然，除了不够直接到背叛我同居的女友——我每晚都要回到她身边，而她实际上足够聪明、足够尊重我，问我：“你对你提到的那个年轻编剧有感觉吗？你一直在关注她。”——我却对她说：“没有。”因为诀窍就是如果你对自己撒谎，你就能对所有人撒谎。这真的很容易。
And so that's what I continued to do, telling myself and anybody that threatened to confront me with it that if you thought what I was doing was creepy or flirty or unprofessional then it's because you were the sexist. You were jealous. I was supporting this person. I'm a mentor, I'm a feminist.
所以我继续这样做，告诉自己以及任何威胁要揭穿我的人：如果你认为我的行为令人毛骨悚然、调情或不专业，那是因为你太性别歧视了。你嫉妒。我在支持这个人。我是导师，我是女权主义者。
It's your problem, not mine. You're the one that actually is seeing things through that lens. And so I let myself keep doing it. And it's not as if this person didn't repeatedly communicate to me the idea that what I was doing was divesting her of a recourse to integrity.
这是你的问题，不是我的。你才是那个真正透过有色眼镜看问题的人。所以我让自己继续那样做。而且并不是说这个人没有反复向我传达这样一个想法：我的行为正在剥夺她维护自身尊严的途径。
Integrity meaning integrity is a writer, learning her craft. This writer told him, when you focus on me, praise me so much, pick my jokes-- if you were doing it for the wrong reasons, even a little bit, that would undermine me devastatingly. How will I know if I'm truly doing my job well?
尊严意味着身为一名作家的尊严，学习她的手艺。这位编剧告诉他：“当你关注我、过度赞扬我、挑选我的笑话时——如果你是因为错误的原因这样做，哪怕只有一点点，那也会毁灭性地破坏我。我怎么知道自己是否真正做好了工作？”
I just didn't hear it. And it's because it didn't profit me to hear it. And this was, after all, happening to me, right? And so after a season of playing it that way I broke up with my girlfriend, who I had lied to the whole time while lying to myself. I broke up with my girlfriend, then I went right, you know, full steam into creepin' on my employee.
我只是没有听进去。因为听进去对我没有好处。毕竟，这是发生在我身上的事，对吧？所以在那样做了一个季度后，我与女友分手了，我一直在对她撒谎，同时也对自己撒谎。我与女友分手了，然后我全力以赴地去骚扰我的员工。
And then after that season, you know, I got overt about my feelings after it was wrapped because then-- and said, oh, I love you. And she said the same thing she'd been saying the entire time, in one language or another. Please, don't you understand that focusing on me like this, liking me like this, preferring me like this, I can't say no to it. And when you do it, it makes me unable to know whether I'm good at my job.
而在那个季度之后，你知道，在一切结束后，我对我的感情变得直接，然后说：“噢，我爱你。”而她说的还是她一直以来都在说的话，无论用什么语言。“请，你不明白吗？像这样关注我，像这样喜欢我，像这样偏爱我，我无法拒绝。当你这样做时，让我无法知道我是否擅长我的工作。”
And because I finally got to the point where I said to her, oh, this is-- you know, I love you, because that's what I thought it was when you target somebody for two years. And it was therefore rejected that way. I was humiliated. And so I continued to do the cowardly thing, and continued to do the selfish thing.
而因为我最终到了那种地步，我对她说：“噢，这就是……你知道，我爱你。”因为当我针对某人两年时，这就是我以为的感觉。因此，我以那种方式被拒绝了。我感到羞辱。所以我继续做懦弱的事，继续做自私的事。
Now I wanted to teach her a lesson. I wanted to show her that if she didn't like being liked in that way, then oh, boy, she should get over herself. After all, if you're just going to be a writer then this is how just writers get treated.
现在我想给她一个教训。我想告诉她，如果她不喜欢以那种方式被喜欢，那么噢，天哪，她应该自我克制。毕竟，如果你只是个写手，那么写手就是这样被对待的。
Did you get what he's saying here? She said, I don't want to date you. His response was, fine. You don't like my praise and attention? All right, then, look out.
你听懂他在这里说什么了吗？她说，我不跟你约会。他的反应是，好啊。你不喜欢我的赞美和关注？好吧，那你等着瞧。
And that was probably the darkest of it all because I drank, I took pills, I crushed on her and resented her for not reciprocating it. And the entire time I was the one writing her paychecks and in control of whether she stayed or went, and whether she felt good about herself or not, and said horrible things. Just treated her cruelly, pointedly. Things that I would never, ever, ever have done if she had been male and if I had never had those feelings for her. And I lied to myself the entire time about it and I lost my job.
而那可能是最黑暗的部分，因为我喝酒，吃药，我迷恋她又因为她没有回报而怨恨她。而整个期间，我才是给她发工资的那个人，掌握着她去留的决定权，掌握着她是否对自己感觉良好，我说了一些可怕的话。就是残忍地、刻意地对待她。如果她是男性，如果我从来没有对她产生过那种感觉，我是绝不可能做这些事的。我整个期间都在对自己撒谎，然后我丢掉了工作。
I feel the need to say, he didn't lose his job because of this woman. She didn't report him to his bosses. He's describing a more general crisis in his life.
我需要说明的是，他丢掉工作并不是因为这个女人。她没有向他的老板举报他。他描述的是他生活中更广泛的危机。
I ruined my show. I betrayed the audience. I destroyed everything. And I damaged her internal compass. And I moved on.
我毁了我的节目。我背叛了观众。我毁了一切。我损害了她的内在指南针。然后我继续前行。
And I never did it before and I will never do it again. But I certainly wouldn't have been able to do it if I had any respect for women. On a fundamental level, I was thinking about them as different creatures. I was thinking about the ones that I liked as having some special role in my life. And I did it all by not thinking about it.
我以前从没做过，以后也绝不会再做。但我如果有对女性的任何尊重，我肯定做不出这种事。在基本层面上，我当时认为她们是不同的生物。我认为我喜欢的人在我的生活中扮演着某种特殊的角色。我这一切都是通过不去思考而做到的。
So I just want to say, in addition to obviously being sorry, but that's really not the important thing, I want to say I did it by not thinking about it. And I got away with it by not thinking about it. And if she hadn't mentioned something on Twitter, I would have continued to not have to think about it, although I did walk around with my stomach in knots about it. But I wouldn't have had to talk about it.
所以我想说，除了显然感到抱歉——但那真的不是重要的——我想说，我是通过不去思考而做到的。而且我通过不去思考而逃脱了惩罚。如果她没有在推特上提到什么，我将继续不必去思考它，尽管我确实带着胃部打结的感觉到处走。但我不需要去谈论它。
The person Dan Harmon was talking about is another writer, Megan Ganz. She's now an executive producer on It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia. When she heard Dan's apology last year, she was in her car on the 101 and 170 in Los Angeles.
丹·哈蒙谈论的那个人是另一位编剧，梅根·甘兹。她现在是《费城永远阳光灿烂》的执行制片人。当她去年听到丹的道歉时，她正在洛杉矶的101号和170号公路上开车。
Yeah, I was driving to work which, about halfway through listening to it, I thought, well, this is a mistake. I probably should have saved this till I got home tonight. Honestly, I started listening to it expecting to be angry. So that was also kind of a roller coaster, going from angry to feeling this immense relief at the end of it. And I listened to it, I think, again right away, sitting in my car in the parking lot of my work.
是的，我当时正开车去上班，听到一半时，我想，嗯，这是一个错误。我可能应该留到今晚回家再听。老实说，我开始听的时候是抱着愤怒的心态。所以这也算是一种过山车，从愤怒到最后感到巨大的解脱。我想我马上又听了一遍，坐在公司停车场里。
When she heard Dan's apology, they hadn't talked face to face in six years.
当她听到丹的道歉时，他们已经有六年没有面对面交谈过了。
It was cathartic in a way that I could have never imagined. It was like receiving the antidote to a poison I'd been self inflicting. It's the only way I can describe it.
这是一种我无法想象的宣泄。就像得到了我一直以来对自己施加的毒药的解药。这是我唯一能描述它的方式。
Megan thanked Dan via text and also forgave him publicly on Twitter, saying quote, "please listen to it. It is a master class in how to apologize. I only listened because I expected an apology, but what I didn't expect was the relief I'd feel hearing him say these things actually happened. Ironic that the only person who could give me that comfort is the one person I'd never ask," end quote.
梅根通过短信感谢了丹，并在推特上公开原谅了他，写道：“请听听它。这是一堂关于如何道歉的大师课。我之所以听，是因为我期待道歉，但我没料到当听到他承认这些事情真的发生过时，我会感到如释重负。讽刺的是，唯一能给我这种安慰的人，竟然是我永远不会要求的那个人。”
Whatever you think of this apology, the content of it, the result was not the way these stories have usually ended. Both parts are unusual-- the apology and the acceptance of it. It's so unusual, I think it's worth looking at how exactly that moment in the car, Megan listening, feeling relieved, how did that come to be? How did they get there, to forgiveness? Could their path be a map for anyone else? I don't know, maybe.
无论你怎么看待这次道歉及其内容，结果与这些故事通常的结局不同。这两个部分都不寻常——道歉和对它的接受。这太不寻常了，我觉得值得看看汽车里的那个时刻，梅根听着，感到解脱，究竟是如何实现的？他们是如何走到宽恕这一步的？他们的道路能成为别人的地图吗？我不知道，也许吧。
A quick outline of their history. Dan was Megan's boss, the creator of a TV show that was pretty much all consuming for the writers who worked on it. It was Megan's first job writing for a sitcom. She was among the least experienced, least powerful people in the room. But Dan was impressed with Megan from her first script and he favored her flagrantly, insisting it was only about her work.
他们的历史简述。丹是梅根的老板，是一个对参与创作的编剧来说几乎占据了全部生活的电视节目的创作者。这是梅根第一份编写情景喜剧的工作。她是房间里资历最浅、权力最小的人之一。但丹从她的第一个剧本开始就对梅根印象深刻，他明目张胆地偏袒她，坚称这只是出于她的工作能力。
When he came clean about his feelings and she said she didn't feel that way, he turned on her, started savaging her work, berating her in front of the other writers. This all went on for about two years, start to finish. The apology that gave her relief-- it did not spring forth all at once. It was actually built out of earlier, not successful apologies.
当他坦白自己的感情而她表示没有这种感觉时，他开始针对她，攻击她的工作，在其他编剧面前斥责她。这一切持续了大约两年，从头到尾。那个让她感到解脱的道歉——并不是一次性喷涌而出的。它实际上是建立在早期不成功的道歉之上的。
The very first one was in 2012, after Dan was fired from Community. Dan texted Megan saying basically, sorry for being a bad boss-- very general, short. Megan felt nothing. Another early attempt was on his podcast, 12 weeks before the apology that stuck. It was more in the nature of an admission than an apology.
第一次是在2012年，丹被《废柴联盟》解雇之后。丹发短信给梅根，基本上说，为做个糟糕的老板感到抱歉——非常笼统、简短。梅根毫无感觉。另一次早期尝试是在他的播客上，就在那个奏效的道歉前的12周。那与其说是道歉，不如说是一种承认。
I have abused my power dynamic at work. I didn't know I was doing it when I did it.
我滥用了我在工作中的权力动态。我在做这件事的时候不知道自己是在滥用。
He drops this excuse in the later apology.
他在后来的道歉中抛弃了这个借口。
I didn't-- I never took notice that-- I never thought to myself, until after the whole thing happened and I looked back and I was like, why was that such a relative disaster? Oh, because if you have a crush on someone that works for you, you are not-- it's not the same as having a crush on someone at a library or a bar that doesn't work for you, you fucking idiot.
我从未注意到——直到整件事发生后我回顾过去，我说，为什么那是一场相对的灾难？噢，因为如果你对为你工作的人有爱慕之情，这跟对图书馆或酒吧里不为你工作的人有爱慕之情是不一样的，你这个蠢货。
Megan didn't hear this at the time. If the possible beginnings of an apology fall in a podcast and no one's there to hear it-- the pace really started picking up on Twitter at the end of 2017 in the wake of Harvey Weinstein, Larry Nassar, Louis CK, on and on. Dan tweeted, quote, "This was truly the year of the asshole, myself included. We don't have to make 2018 the year of the mensch, but I hope it can be the year of the not as much of an asshole. #realisticgoals."
梅根当时没有听到这个。如果道歉的可能开头掉进播客里而没人听……到了2017年底，在哈维·韦恩斯坦、拉里·纳萨尔、路易·CK等人事件之后，推特上的节奏真的加快了。丹发推文说：“这确实是混蛋的一年，也包括我自己。我们不必让2018年成为好人的一年，但我希望它能成为‘不那么混蛋’的一年。#现实目标。”
Megan read that one and what drove her to respond was the reaction she saw-- people praising him for admitting to big bad behavior in the past and declaring he was trying to be better. She wrote back on Twitter.
梅根读到了那条推文，促使她回应的是她看到的反应——人们称赞他承认过去的坏行为并宣称自己在努力变得更好。她在推特上回击道：
I responded to him by saying, care to be more specific? Redemption follows allocution.
我回应他说，愿意具体点吗？救赎随陈述而来。
What does allocution mean? I had to look it up.
“陈述”（Allocution）是什么意思？我得去查查。
Well, it's a term I took from Law and Order, because I'm a big Law and Order fan. Allocuting to a crime is basically what happens when you take a plea deal and the judge says that you have to, as part of the deal, say what you did. And if your allocution is found to be lacking in any way they can pull your plea bargain back, basically. That's how I understand it. So I guess that was a weird mix of my Law and Order knowledge and my Catholicism, Catholic school, coming together because I thought, well, the way that it always worked in confession was, you had to say what you did wrong first before they would absolve you.
嗯，这是我从《法律与秩序》里学到的词，因为我是个《法律与秩序》大粉丝。向犯罪做陈述基本上就是当你达成认罪协议时，法官说作为协议的一部分，你必须陈述你所做的事情。如果你的陈述被认为有任何欠缺，他们基本上可以撤销你的认罪协议。这就是我的理解。所以我猜这是我从《法律与秩序》学到的知识和我天主教背景（天主教学校）的奇怪结合，因为我想，在忏悔中总是这样运作的：在他们赦免你之前，你必须先说出你做错了什么。
Dan tweeted back, saying quote, "I've talked on my podcast about the lines I crossed," end quote. And also, quote, "I will talk about it more in any way that you think is just. I am deeply sorry," end quote. That, I am deeply sorry, was the first time Megan felt like he was speaking directly to her about how he'd behaved with her.
丹回复推文说：“我在我的播客里谈过我越界的那些事。”以及，“我会以你认为公正的任何方式谈论它更多。我深表歉意。”那个“我深表歉意”是梅根第一次感觉到他是直接就自己的行为向她说话。
She says she might have left it there with the deeply sorry except Dan sent out another tweet saying quote, "I'm filled with regret and a lot of foggy memories about abusing my position, treating you like garbage. I would feel a lot of relief if you told me there was a way to fix it. I'll let you call the shots. Till then, at least I know I was an awful boss and a selfish baby," end quote. The foggy memories line got to her.
她说如果丹没有发另一条推文，她可能就此作罢。丹发推文说：“我充满遗憾，对滥用职权、把你像垃圾一样对待的记忆变得模糊。如果你告诉我有一种弥补的方法，我会感到如释重负。我让你决定怎么做。在那之前，至少我知道我曾是个糟糕的老板，是个自私的婴儿。”那句“模糊的记忆”触动了她。
Yeah, I wrote, "I wish my memories were foggier. I wish there was a way to fix it. It took me years to believe in my talents again, to trust a boss when he complimented me and not cringe when he asked for my number. I was afraid to be enthusiastic, knowing it might be turned against me later. You want relief? So do I. Figure out how to give me that relief and I'll return the favor."
是的，我写道：“我希望我的记忆能模糊一点。我希望有一种弥补的方法。我花了几年时间才重新相信自己的才华，才敢在老板夸奖我时信任他，而不是在听到他要我号码时感到战栗。我害怕展现热情，因为知道这可能会在以后被利用来对付我。你想要解脱？我也想要。找出给我那种解脱的方法，我会回报你。”
I guess what I was reading into that tweet was, I was like, you're already thinking of you. You're already thinking of how you can move on from this, instead of just sitting with the awful knowledge that I've been sitting with this for six years. And nobody helped me out of these feelings. Nobody showed me a path back. I had to figure that out for myself.
我猜我在那条推文中解读出的是，我想：你已经在考虑你自己了。你已经在想怎么从这件事中解脱出来，而不是仅仅沉浸在那种可怕的知识中——我已经在这种知识中煎熬了六年。没有人帮我摆脱这些感觉。没有人给我指明回头路。我不得不自己找出办法。
Over the course of this exchange, which went on for a couple more rounds on Twitter, Megan essentially wrote the outline of her own apology. She laid out some specifics that needed to be addressed. I doubted my talent. I didn't know how to act around bosses or co-workers afterward. I am still roiled inside. I have lost time to this. And of course, allocution-- a full account.
在这次交流的过程中，他们在推特上又多来回了几次，梅根实际上写出了她自己道歉的大纲。她列出了一些需要解决的具体事项。我怀疑我的才华。事后我不知道如何对待老板或同事。我内心依然翻腾。我为此浪费了时间。当然，还有陈述——一个完整的交代。
Dan kept saying, I want to do the right thing. Tell me what's the right thing. And Megan kept saying, I appreciate you're trying. Try harder. Dan didn't want to be interviewed on tape. He said he didn't want to make this story about him, any more than it already is. But he answered questions via email and confirmed facts.
丹一直说，我想做正确的事。告诉我什么是正确的事。而梅根一直说，我很感激你在尝试。再努力一点。丹不想接受录音采访。他说他不想让这个故事再变成关于他个人的，因为它本身已经够多了。但他通过电子邮件回答了问题并确认了事实。
Dan said via email that after he read Megan's tweets, his first reactions were fear and self-pity. It was his 45th birthday. He talked to his agents and accepted the possibility that his career in TV might be over. And he had a reaction I've seen other men have-- it felt unfair. He wanted to defend himself.
丹通过电子邮件说，当他读完梅根的推文后，他的第一反应是恐惧和自怜。那天是他45岁生日。他与经纪人交谈，接受了他的电视事业可能已经结束的可能性。他产生了一种我见过其他男人也有过的反应——觉得这不公平。他想为自己辩护。
He says he realized, slowly, that there was no defending himself. He couldn't do it if he was honest. And also, maybe he didn't need to do it because no one was attacking him? He emailed, quote, "someone doesn't have to wish me harm to tell me that I harmed them," end quote. Dan says he got advice from women he knows in the business. And he read a book called, On Apology by Aaron Lazare, recommended by his therapist.
他说他慢慢意识到，没有什么可辩护的。如果他诚实，他就没法辩护。而且，也许他不需要辩护，因为没有人正在攻击他？他写道：“某人不需要希望我受伤害才能告诉我，我伤害了他们。”丹说他从业内认识的女性那里得到了建议。他还读了一本书，书名是《论道歉》，作者是亚伦·拉扎雷，是他治疗师推荐的。
Lazare says a complete apology has to start with quote, "an acknowledgment of offense, i.e. wrenching your brain away from its justifications and putting yourself in the other person's place." as Dan put it via email quote, "it seems crucial that you not skimp there." He said part of not skimping with Megan was to face that, quote, "I could have had the same feelings I had and not caused damage. I could have shared the feelings and been told they weren't reciprocated and not caused damage," end quote.
拉扎雷说，一个完整的道歉必须以“承认冒犯开始，即把你从自己的辩护理由中拉出来，将你自己放在对方的位置上。”正如丹在电子邮件中所说：“在这一点上不吝啬似乎至关重要。”他说，对梅根“不吝啬”的一部分就是要面对这样一个事实：“我本可以拥有同样的感情，但并没有造成伤害。我本可以分享这种感情，被告知没有得到回报，而并没有造成伤害。”
Apologies are powerful-- they can be. But power is also amoral. It can be used for a pernicious goal as easily as a better one. One reason Megan needed a full account of Dan's intentional damage, and not just a big, I am deeply sorry, is that Dan actually apologized to Megan a lot back when she worked for him. It was part of the slow buildup of the harassment.
道歉很有力量——它们可以如此。但权力也是非道德的。它被用于邪恶目标与被用于更好目标一样容易。梅根需要丹对他蓄意伤害的完整交代，而不仅仅是一句响亮的“我深表歉意”，原因之一是丹在梅根为他工作时实际上曾多次向梅根道歉。这是骚扰缓慢积累过程的一部分。
Megan was 25 when she started writing on Community. Dan was 37, creator and show runner. In the room there was this imaginary lack of hierarchy that a lot of creative endeavors have-- we're all just making a cool thing together. The best idea wins. That vibe is a lot easier to surf when you're older and can appreciate the ways in which it's true while seeing all the ways in which it's ridiculous.
梅根开始在《废柴联盟》工作时才25岁。丹37岁，是创作者和剧集主管。在房间里有一种许多创意努力所共有的虚构的无层级感——我们都在一起制作酷东西。最好的主意获胜。当你年纪较大，能欣赏到它在某些方面是真实的同时又能看到它在所有方面是多么荒谬时，那种氛围更容易驾驭。
And of course, the notion of a pure meritocracy is easy to believe in to the point of delusion when you're on the winning side. Megan didn't want to rehash specific incidents with Dan on the radio, but she did talk about the way apologizing was a key part of the dynamic.
当然，当你在获胜一方时，纯粹精英管理的理念很容易被相信到近乎幻觉的地步。梅根不想在广播里重提与丹的具体事件，但她谈到了道歉如何成为这种动态的关键部分。
Like for instance, he would do something, say something to me that I wouldn't take as inappropriate. And then he would apologize for it, for some little thing that he had said. And I would say, oh, don't worry about it. Like, I wasn't offended. And then the thing, the next thing that would happen, would be slightly more inappropriate.
比如，他会对我做某事、说某事，我原本不会认为是不恰当的。然后他会为这件事、为他说过的一些小事道歉。我会说，噢，别担心。我没觉得被冒犯。然后接下来发生的事会稍微更不恰当一点。
But I had forgiven him for one thing and I thought, oh-- every time that he apologized I thought, well, look, this guy is-- he knows. Like, he's real switched on. He knows where the line is. Not realizing that all of those instances were slowly moving the line to a place where I had forgiven him so many times that it started to become maybe something that didn't seem that big of a deal to me. And had the last interaction happened first, maybe I would have had a stronger reaction.
但我已经原谅了他的一件事，我想，噢——每次他道歉时，我都想，看，这个人……他懂的。他知道底线在哪里。没意识到所有这些实例都在缓慢地将底线移动到一个位置，在这个位置，我已经原谅了他那么多次，以至于它开始变得好像对我来说不是什么大不了的事。如果最后那次互动先发生，也许我会反应更强烈。
Megan could see that other writers on the show, more experienced writers, noticed Dan's focus on her, his eagerness to choose her jokes, to leapfrog her into opportunities they'd had to work years to get. People made little comments in front of her, or jokes about her favored status.
梅根能看出剧组里的其他编剧，更有经验的编剧，注意到了丹对她的关注，他急于选择她的笑话，让她跳级获得他们不得不工作多年才能获得的各种机会。人们在她面前发表小评论，或拿她受优待的状态开玩笑。
Yeah. Yeah, I mean, instead of in that moment thinking, oh, my god, are people picking up on something here that I'm not picking up on? I thought, well, you're just jealous. You're jealous that I'm doing better at this job than you are. And he would say things to me like, I never want you to think that my interest in you is anything other than professional. I think you're a really great writer. And I reward you because I feel that you're a great writer. And I wanted to believe that so badly that I, in wanting to believe that we're all equal and that there isn't any sort of untoward affection going on, I was not looking at it. I wasn't perceiving it.
是的。是的，我的意思是，在那一刻我没有想“噢，天哪，人们是不是察觉到了我没察觉的东西？”，我反而想，你是嫉妒。你嫉妒我比你做得更好。他会对我那样说，像“我从不希望你认为我对你的兴趣是职业以外的任何东西。我认为你是个很棒的编剧。我奖励你是因为我觉得你是个很棒的编剧。”我非常渴望相信这一点，以至于在渴望相信我们都是平等的、没有发生任何不当的爱慕关系的情况下，我没有去观察它。我没有觉察到。
And then when Dan told her he loved her and she turned him down and he began punishing her, that's when Megan caught up to some of the other writers' perception of what had been going on the whole time.
然后当丹告诉她他爱她，而她拒绝了他，他开始惩罚她时，梅根才赶上了其他编剧对整件事的认知。
Yes, it felt like-- I know it sounds silly. It felt like an M Night Shyamalan twist at the end, where all of a sudden you have these flashes of all these things that happened and you realized, oh, my god.
是的，感觉就像……我知道这听起来很傻。感觉就像结尾处的一个M·奈特·沙马兰式的转折，突然之间，你闪回了所有发生过的事情，然后意识到，噢，天哪。
All these people are dead!
所有这些人都是死的！
It was sexual harassment the whole time.
从头到尾就是性骚扰。
Megan says she loves Community. It's one of her favorite shows of all time, still. She wrote one of the funniest episodes. Writing on the show was collaborative, but she is the credited writer on this one. It's a Law and Order parody, of course. The murder victim was a yam, part of a biology experiment.
梅根说她热爱《废柴联盟》。它仍然是她最喜欢的节目之一。她写了最有趣的一集。该剧的编写是协作完成的，但这一集她是署名编剧。当然，这是《法律与秩序》的模仿剧。谋杀受害者是一个山药，一个生物实验的一部分。
Remember the characters are all students at a community college. Grades were at stake, motives were complex. There's a quasi trial scene out of A Few Good Men. Donald Glover plays one of the detectives, Michael K Williams, who plays Omar on The Wire, is the biology teacher.
记住这些角色都是社区大学的学生。成绩受到威胁，动机复杂。有一个来自《好人寥寥》的准审判场景。唐纳德·格洛弗扮演侦探之一，在《火线》中扮演奥马尔的迈克尔·K·威廉姆斯是生物老师。
The actors are having a ball. There's so many layers of jokes-- jokes within jokes. It's just a delicious piece of pop culture baklava. How are you supposed to tell that someone who says you're really talented has another agenda when you are, in fact, really talented?
演员们玩得很开心。有太多的笑话层级——笑话中的笑话。这只是流行文化果仁蜜饼的一道美味。当你实际上真的很有才华时，你该如何辨别一个说你非常有才华的人是否有其他议程？
There's this thing of like, you have this experience that only one other person shared and you can't talk to that person about it because they're the cause of your pain. So, hearing him be so specific, especially about how when I rejected his feelings, how quickly that turn happened to the punishment for having rejected him-- that's how quick it felt to me. But having him say that he made that choice consciously, and the fact that he said I treated her in a way that I wouldn't have done if she was a man, just can't be understated, like how important that is to hear.
有这样一种感觉，就是你有过只有另一个人分享的经历，而且你无法与那个人谈论它，因为他们就是你痛苦的根源。所以，听到他如此具体，特别是关于当我拒绝他的感情时，那种转变对惩罚我的发生有多快——对我来说感觉有多快。但让他说出他是清醒地做出了那个选择，以及他说“我对待她的方式如果她是男性我是绝不会做的”，这怎么强调都不为过，这是多么重要。
In his apology, Dan urged his fans not to attack Megan. And most of the responses she got were positive. Some of the writers from Community reached out. Women she didn't know got in touch to tell her they'd lived vicariously through her apology-- said they'd never gotten ones of their own. Dan ended his apology with a lot of hope.
在道歉中，丹敦促他的粉丝不要攻击梅根。她得到的大多数回应都是积极的。一些《废柴联盟》的编剧联系了她。她不认识的女性也联系她，告诉她她们通过她的道歉产生了共鸣——说她们从来没有得到过属于自己的道歉。丹的道歉结尾充满了希望。
And I think that we're living in a good time right now because we're not going to get away with it anymore.
我认为我们现在生活在一个美好的时代，因为我们不会再那样逃脱惩罚了。
He said via email he feels less optimistic now. He said one of the few responses he's gotten from men since he apologized was a guy who reached out to say how he felt frustrated that Dan had quote, gotten away with it, end quote, and he hadn't. And he wanted to know what he could do to get away with it, because Dan's still working in TV.
他在邮件中说他现在感到不那么乐观了。他说，自从他道歉以来，他从男性那里得到的少数回应之一，是一个联系他的人，说他感到沮丧，因为丹“逃脱了惩罚”，而他却没有。他想知道他能做什么来逃脱惩罚，因为丹还在电视行业工作。
Dan's apology worked, partly because he finally took a risk. He admitted to things that, if Meghan had wanted she probably could have used against him. Lawyers advised him not to say those things, he says on the podcast. By admitting them openly, he chose her well-being over his own comfort, maybe for the first time in their whole relationship. A lot of people just aren't willing to do that, even for seven and a half minutes.
丹的道歉奏效了，部分原因是他终于冒了险。他承认了一些如果梅根想要，她可能可以用来对付他的事情。他在播客上说，律师建议他不要说这些。通过公开承认它们，他选择了她的福祉而不是他自己的舒适，也许这是他们整个关系中的第一次。很多人只是不愿意这样做，哪怕只是七分半钟。
Nancy Updike is a producer on our show. Coming up, starlings and finches and crows, oh my! Why spiders and mollusks and slugs should hate their guts. I mean, OK, a new reason why they should hate their guts that you've never heard of. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人。接下来，椋鸟、雀鸟和乌鸦，噢，天哪！为什么蜘蛛、软体动物和蛞蝓应该恨它们入骨。我是说，好的，一个你从未听说过的它们应该恨它们入骨的新理由。那是一分钟后，当我们的节目在芝加哥公共广播电台继续时。
This is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Get a Spine!" Stories of people standing up for themselves, shaking off their fear, bracing themselves and doing what they have been scared to do. And as we were putting together today's show, we put out this call looking for people who are actually in that situation of having to face something that freaked them out. And by face it I mean, face it right now. Over 200 people wrote in, people square in the front of big, life changing moments, and some smaller ones too. Here's a brief catalog of spines recently grown across the country.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“长出脊骨！”讲述人们为自己站出来、甩掉恐惧、鼓起勇气、做他们一直害怕做的事情的故事。当我们制作今天的节目时，我们发出了这个呼吁，寻找那些实际上处于不得不面对让他们感到恐惧的事情的境地的人。我说的面对，是指此时此刻面对。超过200人写信来，人们正处于重大、改变人生的时刻，也有一些较小的时刻。这是一个全国各地最近长出脊骨的简短目录。
My name is Zoey. I am almost eight years old. I'm about to try to dive off the diving board. It makes me feel nervous but I don't know why.
我叫佐伊。我快八岁了。我正要尝试从跳板上跳下去。这让我感到紧张，但我不知道为什么。
I am at North Heights Lutheran Church in Roseville, Minnesota. And in about 20 minutes we're going to start the service. I'm going to preach my first sermon. I sat at my desk today at work and read through it kind of softly so no one could hear. Tonight after work I actually read through it full volume and I was walking around the room like I normally would in the church. I was holding my Bible. My wife actually came and interrupted me and she's like, it's time for dinner but you're doing a great job, so she could hear me from down the hall.
我在明尼苏达州罗斯维尔的北高地路德教会。大约20分钟后我们将开始礼拜。我要发表我的第一次布道。我今天在工作时坐在桌旁，轻轻地读了一遍，以免被别人听到。今晚下班后，我实际上以全音量读了一遍，像平时在教堂那样在房间里走动。我拿着我的圣经。我妻子实际上来打断了我，她说：“该吃晚饭了，但你做得很好。”所以她在走廊那边也能听到我的声音。
I am about to have my first baby. I guess I'm nervous for how long it could take, and to get too tired. I've been thinking a lot about like, what I eat because I want to make sure that something that it's going to fill me up and things like that.
我快要生第一个宝宝了。我想我对这可能需要多长时间以及太累感到紧张。我一直在想很多关于“我吃什么”的问题，因为我想确保那是我能吃饱的东西之类的。
What did you eat today?
你今天吃了什么？
A fried egg.
一个煎蛋。
I'm Michael.
我是迈克尔。
And I'm Piper.
我是派珀。
And we're in our bedroom.
我们在我们的卧室里。
And we're about to have sex for the very first time.
我们正要第一次发生性关系。
I'm excited.
我很兴奋。
Me, too. A little bit nervous?
我也是。有点紧张吗？
A little bit nervous. It'll work out.
有点紧张。会没事的。
It's the kind of thing where, you know no matter what it's going to be weird the first time. But, it's only going to get better from here. So, why not start now?
这就像是那种，无论如何，第一次总是会很奇怪的事情。但它只会从这里开始变得更好。所以，为什么不现在就开始呢？
I love you.
我爱你。
I love you, too.
我也爱你。
I do not want to be married anymore. I'm finally able-- I'm admitting, OK, I did all the things. Let's go.
我不想再结婚了。我终于能——我承认，好的，我做了所有该做的事。我们走吧。
On Saturday at the end of this week I have to deliver my mother's eulogy. You know, what I really need to do is focus on just really honoring her memory. But I'm a little angry with her, a little angry with myself, and a little angry at the universe for, this is the way things played out.
这周六，我必须发表我母亲的悼词。你知道，我真正需要做的是专注于真正缅怀她的记忆。但我对她有点生气，对自己有点生气，对宇宙有点生气，因为，这就是事情发展的方式。
So Zoey, they're moving a lap lane so that you can use the diving board. How does that make you feel?
所以佐伊，他们正在移动游泳道，这样你就可以使用跳板了。这让你感觉如何？
Excited and nervous.
兴奋又紧张。
Ready to give it a try.
准备好尝试一下了。
I don't know.
我不知道。
Well, honey, there isn't-- unfortunately there's a little bit of pressure here because they're giving you a special chance to do it, but the board's still supposed to be closed. So now's your chance.
嗯，宝贝，不幸的是，这里有一点压力，因为他们给了你一个特别的机会来做这件事，但板子本来应该是关闭的。所以现在是你的机会了。
I don't think I want to.
我不觉得我想做。
Today is not the day?
今天不是那个日子？
Yes.
是的。
All right, today is not the day.
好吧，今天不是那个日子。
What do we say to the god of diving? Not today. Those voices were collected by Aviva DeKornfeld and Diane Wu.
我们对跳水之神说什么？今天不行。这些声音由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德和黛安·吴收集。
Which brings us to Act Two, Act Two of our program, Because You're Spine, I Walk the Line.
这把我们带到了第二幕，我们节目的第二幕，《因为你有脊骨，我走直线》。
So our show today is about the spineless getting a spine. And in this act we turned to those who are truly spineless and by that I mean literally, they are literally creatures who have no spines. Also featured in the story, the scientists who study them, who, like us all, could sometimes use a little more spine. Lilly Sullivan explains.
所以我们今天的节目是关于没骨气的人长出脊骨。在这一幕中，我们转向那些真正没骨气的，我的意思是字面意思，他们字面意思上是脊椎动物，他们是没有脊骨的生物。故事中还有研究它们的科学家，他们像我们所有人一样，有时也需要多一点脊骨。莉莉·沙利文解释说。
A while back I was talking to my friend Jackie and she tells me, oh man, Malcolm started a bunch of drama at work. Malcolm's her husband. And that surprised me because Malcolm's workplace has never struck me as all that traumatic. Here's Jackie.
前阵子我和我的朋友杰基聊天，她告诉我：“噢，天哪，马尔科姆在工作中制造了一堆戏码。”马尔科姆是她丈夫。这让我很惊讶，因为马尔科姆的工作场所从来没让我觉得有什么创伤性。这是杰基。
He works with spiders, wolf spiders. Like, the bulk of his research has been about wolf spiders mating. He watches wolf spiders have sex.
他和蜘蛛一起工作，狼蛛。就像，他研究的大部分内容都是关于狼蛛交配。他观察狼蛛做爱。
Malcolm Rosenthal, he's a scientist, a behavioral ecologist. And wolf spiders, if that name sounds wild it's actually one of the most common spiders out there-- brown, nondescript. If you turn over a rock and you see a spider, it's likely a wolf spider.
马尔科姆·罗森塔尔，他是一位科学家，行为生态学家。而狼蛛，如果那个名字听起来很狂野，它实际上是那里最常见的蜘蛛之一——棕色，不起眼。如果你翻开一块石头，看到一只蜘蛛，它很可能是狼蛛。
He thinks they're cute now. Like, he frequently calls them like, they're like little puppies! They look at me with their little puppy eyes.
他现在觉得它们很可爱。就像，他经常称它们为“它们就像小狗！它们用它们那双小狗眼看着我。”
They're kind of like little puppies. They look around at you, they follow you, they-- you know, watching the males do these sad little dances and try to get the attention of a mate, and fail more often than not. You can't watch that 1,000 times without getting a little bit attached. Yeah, spiders are shockingly charismatic.
它们有点像小狗。它们看着你，跟着你，它们——你知道，看着雄性表演这些可悲的小舞，试图引起配偶的注意，结果往往以失败告终。你看过1000次就不能不产生一点依恋。是的，蜘蛛具有惊人的魅力。
Now I think you've gone too far.
现在我觉得你太过分了。
Nope. Let's go a little further. That sad little sex dance, the spider's serenade while they do it.
不。让我们再深入一点。那个悲伤的小性爱舞蹈，蜘蛛做那个动作时的短曲。
Oh, no, I'm going to have to do my song impersonation. [IMITATING WOLF SPIDER SONG]
噢，不，我得表演一下我的歌唱模仿了。[模仿狼蛛歌声]
Anyway, here's how the drama started. Jackie's a journalist but she'd often hang out with Malcolm and his spider co-workers. They'd go to this one bar every week. And they'd often end up doing what co-workers do.
不管怎样，戏码就是这样开始的。杰基是一名记者，但她经常和马尔科姆以及他的蜘蛛同事们混在一起。他们每周都会去这家酒吧。他们经常会做同事们做的事情。
They're like, complaining about work. They're complaining about like, the gossip. It's just workplace shit talking, but like, scientists.
他们就像在抱怨工作。他们在抱怨像……八卦。这只是工作场所的吐槽，但就像……科学家。
They're giving Jackie the scoop on the thing they're all worked up about. There'd been a big meeting earlier that week with a bunch of people in the animal behavior department. So it was the spider lab, the cricket lab, and the bird lab. Someone had just heard that a paper they'd submitted to a journal had been rejected.
他们给杰基提供了他们一直在忙活的事情的内幕。那天早些时候举行了一次大型会议，动物行为系的很多人都参加了。所以那是蜘蛛实验室、蟋蟀实验室和鸟类实验室。有人刚听说他们提交给期刊的一篇论文被拒绝了。
My PhD advisor just casually said, oh, well, of course, it probably has something to do with the fact that it's so much harder to get things published when you work with invertebrates. And this other guy, who coincidentally worked with birds--
我的博士导师只是随意地说：“噢，好吧，当然，这可能与这样一个事实有关：当你研究无脊椎动物时，发表文章要困难得多。”而另一个人，恰好研究鸟类——
Birds-- not invertebrates.
鸟类——不是无脊椎动物。
--kind of took offense to that and said, that's not true. That's ridiculous. And then it kind of turned into a whole heated argument over whether this was true or not. And none of us really had any evidence beyond our own experiences. And you know, our experiences were that we felt this was happening and his was that he felt like it wasn't, which I guess isn't surprising given what we worked with. And I remember just being steamed about it.
——有点被冒犯了，说：“那不是真的。那太荒谬了。”然后这变成了一场关于这是否属实的激烈争论。而且我们都没有超出自身经验的证据。你知道，我们的经验是我们觉得这正在发生，而他觉得没有发生，考虑到我们研究的对象，这也不奇怪。我记得当时只是对这件事感到愤怒。
Among invertebrate scientists, people like Malcolm who study spineless creatures, there's a feeling that worms, beetles, mollusks, kind of get the shaft and that people who study animals with spines-- finches, chimpanzees, the fricking bottlenose dolphin-- they're the golden children of animal behavioral research. Malcolm calls this the vertebrate divide.
在无脊椎动物科学家中，像马尔科姆这样研究无脊椎动物的人，有一种感觉，即蠕虫、甲虫、软体动物，有点受到了冷遇，而研究有脊骨动物的人——雀鸟、黑猩猩、该死的宽吻海豚——他们是动物行为研究的宠儿。马尔科姆称此为脊椎动物鸿沟。
Maybe the broad strokes version of it would be that there is a lot of research done on birds and mammals, specifically. And that for those of us that don't study this kind of very special group of organisms there is a sense that the work we do is valued less, or is at least given less airtime. I mean, this is definitely the number one bar topic when you get a bunch of invertebrate scientists drunk together-- which happens a lot, actually.
也许宽泛地说，会有很多关于鸟类和哺乳动物的具体研究。对于我们这些不研究这种非常特殊生物群的人来说，有一种感觉是我们所做的工作价值较低，或者至少得到的曝光时间较少。我的意思是，这绝对是当你们一群无脊椎动物科学家喝醉在一起时的第一话题——这种情况其实经常发生。
The fact that the bird guy not only didn't know about any of that but also told them they were wrong, it infuriated Malcolm. And it stuck with him. He couldn't let it go. Months passed and he and Jackie moved to Canada. Jackie's excited to explore their new neighborhood and Malcolm is still thinking about that fight.
事实上，研究鸟类的人不仅不知道任何这些，还告诉他们错了，这激怒了马尔科姆。这件事萦绕在他心头。他无法放下。几个月过去了，他和杰基搬到了加拿大。杰基很兴奋去探索他们的新社区，而马尔科姆还在想那场争吵。
We went out to breakfast and he was like, yeah, and he said this thing and I still can't believe that he said that bird papers don't get published more. And I think I said, like, oh, well, is there a way that we could-- is there a way to prove that? Or is there a way that you could find out if bird papers or vertebrates get published more than spider papers?
我们出去吃早餐，他说：“是的，他说过那件事，我仍然无法相信他说鸟类论文发表得不多。”我想我当时说：“噢，好吧，有没有办法我们可以……有没有办法证明这一点？或者有没有办法你可以查出鸟类或脊椎动物论文是否比蜘蛛论文发表得更多？”
He couldn't actually get a list of all the rejected animal papers ever written, though he thought about it. But there was a next best thing.
他实际上无法得到有史以来所有被拒绝的动物论文清单，虽然他想过。但还有下一个最好的选择。
And then I think he made a joke about like, yeah, if you went through the whole archive of a journal and went through and looked at every paper they'd ever published. And I was like, can you do that? Is that-- like, is that possible? And he was like, yeah, I guess you could do that. I mean, yeah. I was like, I could do it. We could just like split up the data set at night, because we always like watching dumb TV in the evenings. But I don't think he was actually going to do it.
然后我想他开了一个玩笑，就像“是的，如果你仔细检查期刊的整个档案，去查看他们发表过的每一篇论文。”我说：“你能做到吗？那是……就像，那有可能吗？”他说：“是的，我想你可以做到。我的意思是，是的。”我说：“我可以做到。我们晚上可以拆分数据集合，因为我们晚上喜欢看无聊的电视。”但我没觉得他真的会去做。
A few weeks later, Malcolm had to attend a mandatory training session about biosafety techniques-- nine hours of training and videos about proper glove use, lab coats, a three hour presentation on how to use a special kind of biology cabinet which are for like-- never mind. Malcolm would never have to use them anyway.
几周后，马尔科姆不得不参加一次关于生物安全技术的强制培训课程——九小时的培训和关于正确戴手套、实验室外套的视频，还有一个关于如何使用一种特殊类型生物柜的三小时演讲，这种柜子是用于……不管了。马尔科姆根本就不需要使用它们。
So I was bored. I was so fucking bored. I was so bored that I just went to the journal Animal Behaviour's website, and just started downloading every single paper that they'd published, and just copying down what the animal was for every single paper. And then by the end of three hours I had like, 400 papers done.
我当时很无聊。我他妈的太无聊了。我太无聊了，以至于我只是去了《动物行为》期刊的网站，开始下载他们发表的每一篇论文，并为每一篇论文记下动物是什么。三小时后，我完成了大约400篇论文。
And you start doing this thing just because you're bored out of your mind?
你开始做这件事只是因为你无聊得要死？
Bored, and a little bit of spite maybe towards that person who disagreed with me during that conversation. Like, how cool would it be just to throw this massive data set down on this table and be like, ah! I told you!
无聊，也许还有一点对那个在谈话中不同意我的人的恶意。就像，把这个巨大的数据集扔在桌子上说：“啊！我告诉过你了！”该有多酷啊！
Malcolm picked one of the flagship journals in the field of animal behavior, which is called Animal Behaviour. He picked it because it had 61 years worth of publications. It's a good indicator of what's going on in the field. And he starts going through, paper by paper, counting up. How many papers on birds? How many on insects? Like a scorecard for every living creature.
马尔科姆选择了动物行为领域的一家旗舰期刊，名为《动物行为》。他选择它是因为它有61年的出版历史。这是该领域正在发生什么的一个很好的指标。他开始一篇一篇地检查，数着。有多少关于鸟类的论文？有多少关于昆虫的？就像每一只活物的记分卡。
He hires a bunch of undergrads to help out. There's estimated to be something like 10 million species out there-- most haven't been studied at all and a few have been studied a ton. Here's what he found.
他雇了一些本科生来帮忙。估计那里大约有1000万个物种——大多数根本没有被研究过，而少数被研究得很多。这是他发现的结果。
I mean, I hate to just throw numbers out instead of emotions, but birds and mammals together are less than one half of one half of 1% of all species and they represent half of all papers published in the past 50 years. I don't know, it just kind of-- I find it almost hard to imagine. I mean, if 99% of all animals are not them-- and it was even crazier than that. I mean, 20% of all papers published are published on passerines, which is a subset of birds.
我的意思是，我讨厌只抛出数字而不是情感，但鸟类和哺乳动物总共不到所有物种的万分之五，它们代表了过去50年发表的所有论文的一半。我不知道，这只是有点……我觉得几乎难以想象。我的意思是，如果所有动物的99%不是它们——而且情况甚至比这更疯狂。我的意思是，发表的所有论文中有20%是关于雀形目的，这是鸟类的一个子集。
So it's not even like it's all birds. It's the perching birds, the little chirpy tweet birds, the ones that aren't ostriches or birds of prey. And it's really this tiny, tiny little group. And then within them, it's really just starlings and finches and crows.
所以这甚至不像是一切都是鸟类。这是栖木鸟，那些小鸣禽，那些不是鸵鸟或猛禽的鸟类。这确实是一个非常、非常小的群体。而在它们内部，确实只是椋鸟、雀鸟和乌鸦。
Starlings and finches and crows are to behavioral ecology what the golden retriever is to living rooms across America-- beloved and ubiquitous. But the stuff he found went way beyond birds and bugs. He discovered that just 10 species of animals represented a shockingly high proportion of papers published-- 15% of all papers. That means one in seven papers is dedicated to just 10 species out of millions.
椋鸟、雀鸟和乌鸦对行为生态学来说，就像金毛猎犬对美国家庭客厅一样——深受喜爱且无处不在。但他发现的东西远远超出了鸟类和昆虫。他发现仅仅10种动物就代表了发表论文中惊人高的比例——所有论文的15%。这意味着七分之一的论文专门针对几百万物种中的仅仅10种。
The magnitude of it was so totally shocking to me.
它的规模让我感到完全震惊。
It's a lot worse than you thought?
它比你想象的糟糕得多？
Oh, it's a lot worse. It's so much worse than I thought that I think it really-- it totally floored me. You know, we talk about the natural world and all the animals in it and all the things they do. But if you think you know the world because you've studied hundreds and hundreds of birds and mammals, maybe you don't know the world. Like, maybe it isn't that bad but maybe the whole world is different than we thought because we just haven't been focusing our attention on the bulk of things. Yeah, like we've been only looking at just a tiny sliver and we thought it was the whole world.
噢，它糟糕得多。它比我预想的糟糕得多，以至于我觉得它真的……它完全击倒了我。你知道，我们谈论自然世界和其中的所有动物以及它们所做的一切事情。但如果你认为你知道这个世界，因为你研究了成百上千种鸟类和哺乳动物，也许你根本不知道这个世界。就像，也许它没有那么糟糕，但也许整个世界与我们想象的不同，因为我们只是没有把注意力集中在大部分事物上。是的，就像我们一直只看这一个小片断，我们却以为它是整个世界。
Not everyone sees it this way. I talked to a prominent bird scientist, William Searcy, who actually for six years was an editor of the journal that Malcolm analyzed. He told me he wasn't all that surprised by the findings. Everyone knows that more papers come out on vertebrates than on invertebrates. But he didn't agree that that's some big problem.
并非每个人都这样看。我采访了一位著名的鸟类科学家威廉·瑟西，他在马尔科姆分析的期刊担任过六年的编辑。他告诉我，他对这些发现并不感到惊讶。每个人都知道关于脊椎动物发表的论文比无脊椎动物多。但他不同意这是一个大问题。
As for birds, there are lots of very good reasons to study them. For one thing, they're bigger. You can see them, observe them, study them in their natural habitat. And they do interesting things that other animals don't do-- the way they communicate. They can even develop and learn dialects.
至于鸟类，研究它们有很多很好的理由。首先，它们更大。你可以看到它们、观察它们、在它们的自然栖息地研究它们。它们做一些其他动物不做的事情——它们交流的方式。它们甚至能发展和学习方言。
Also, we've studied them for ages. We know a lot about them. So you can build on that research and make progress, really understand stuff in detail. But his main argument is this-- scientist should first identify a question, a theory that they want to explore, and then pick the species that best helps them explore that question. He says that's how science moves forward.
此外，我们研究它们已经很久了。我们对它们了解很多。所以你可以建立在这些研究的基础上取得进步，真正详细地理解事物。但他主要的论点是这个——科学家应该首先确定一个问题、一个他们想探索的理论，然后选择最能帮助他们探索那个问题的物种。他说这就是科学前进的方式。
He thinks that prioritizing the animal over the question could lead to inferior science. Like, to try to study every kind of beetle-- and there are a lot, something like 450,000 species known so far-- would be untenable, he says. Malcolm says he's not arguing that there should be 450,000 papers on beetles for every one paper on starlings, just that maybe things are so out of whack that we're missing things and we don't even know what we're missing.
他认为优先考虑动物而不是问题可能会导致劣质科学。就像，试图研究每一种甲虫——目前已知的有很多，大约45万种——他说这是站不住脚的。马尔科姆说他并不是争论说每发表一篇关于椋鸟的论文就应该有45万篇关于甲虫的论文，只是也许事情已经如此失调，以至于我们错过了事物，甚至不知道我们错过了什么。
Malcolm figures, if he could just lay out the facts it might get people thinking. They're scientists, after all. His plan is that he'll present all his numbers at this annual conference of the Animal Behavior Society, which is called the Annual Conference of the Animal Behavior Society. All the prominent people will be there, who are mostly bird and mammal scientists because that's how it goes. This is in 2016.
马尔科姆认为，如果他能列出事实，也许能让人们思考。毕竟他们是科学家。他的计划是，他将在动物行为协会的这次年会（称为动物行为协会年会）上展示他所有的数字。所有杰出人物都会在那里，他们主要是鸟类和哺乳动物科学家，因为情况就是这样。这是在2016年。
You know, I'm still relatively early in my career. I don't need to be pissing off people who might later be able to give me a job. And I was really worried that the big names would come to the audience and get grumpy. I guess it's kind of the tame science version of speaking truth to power.
你知道，我的职业生涯还相对较早。我不需要惹恼那些稍后可能给我工作的人。我真的很担心大人物会来到观众席并变得脾气暴躁。我想这算是驯服科学版的“对权力说真话”。
Mm. Were you nervous?
嗯。你紧张吗？
Oh, obviously, I was terrified.
噢，当然，我吓坏了。
He goes on stage and he does his PowerPoint. Jackie's at home during all this. She doesn't usually go to Malcolm's conferences. She'd kind of forgotten when his talk was since they usually just talk at night so she was surprised when Malcolm texted her mid-afternoon.
他走上舞台，播放他的PowerPoint。杰基在这一切期间在家。她通常不去马尔科姆的会议。她有点忘记了他的演讲时间，因为他们通常只在晚上聊天，所以当马尔科姆下午中段发短信给杰基时，她感到很惊讶。
He was like, I just presented my paper and it was bonkers. He described it to me as the most raucous animal behavior panel he'd ever been to.
他说：“我刚刚发表了我的论文，简直疯了。”他向我形容这是他参加过的最喧闹的动物行为小组。
Wow.
哇。
I mean, science conferences are not exciting places. And I didn't think people would go nuts for it.
我的意思是，科学会议不是令人兴奋的地方。我没觉得人们会为它疯狂。
It has to be the coolest talk I have ever given, and probably the coolest talk I will ever give. Just the most outrageous 11 minutes I have experienced in a conference.
这一定是我做过的最酷的演讲，而且可能是我做过的最酷的演讲。只是我在会议中经历的最令人发指的11分钟。
How was it outrageous?
它怎么就令人发指了？
So, these things are pretty staid usually. This talk was like being at a rock concert. People were yelling at me from the seats.
所以，这些东西通常很沉闷。这次演讲就像是在摇滚音乐会上一样。人们从座位上对我大喊大叫。
What were they yelling?
他们在喊什么？
They were screaming-- someone definitely stood up and yelled, "hell, yeah," at me, which might be relatively tame but for a science conference is outrageous. People were standing up, there was applause in the middle-- which never happens. You get tame, sad applause at the end. People were packing the room till there was no space to sit and people were standing jammed in the door frames, which is a great, awesome feeling, and has never happened to me before or since. It was weird.
他们在尖叫——有人绝对站起来对我大喊“去他的，是的”，这可能相对温和，但对于科学会议来说是令人发指的。人们站了起来，中间有掌声——这从来没有发生过。你在最后会得到驯服、悲伤的掌声。人们把房间塞满了，直到没有空间坐，人们被挤在门框里，这是一种很棒、很赞的感觉，这在我之前或之后从未发生过。这很奇怪。
The end was basically a call to action. We were saying like, we think it's time for people to start paying attention to this. And we were getting cheers and fist pumps from the audience. It was nuts.
结尾基本上是一个行动号召。我们说：“我们认为人们是时候开始关注这一点了。”我们从观众那里得到了欢呼和拳头碰触。这太疯狂了。
Fist pumps?
拳头碰触？
Yeah. And the whole rest of the conference, people I didn't know were patting me on the back, which I really hate. I don't like being touched. But people would come up and say like, hey, man, I super love your talk. My name is Mark and I work on butterfly nest site locations.
是的。在会议的其余部分，我不认识的人拍着我的背，我真的很讨厌。我不喜欢被触碰。但人们会走过来说：“嘿，伙计，我超级喜欢你的演讲。我叫马克，我研究蝴蝶巢穴位置。”
It was like, people had been sitting there with all these feelings with no way to talk about them until now. It was like the people who studied the millions of species that did not have a spine, they now had a leader, one with lots of spine who was finally standing up to the authorities with their spiny menagerie of chimps and finches and dolphins and making them listen. And now that invertebrate scientists had seen how the bar graphs were stacked against them, they did not want it to end there. Like this one guy at the conference started counting audience members at every talk, looking for patterns of preferential treatment.
就像，人们一直坐在那里，怀着所有这些感觉，却没有任何方式谈论它们，直到现在。就像那些研究没有脊骨的数百万物种的人，他们现在有了一个领袖，一个拥有很多脊骨的人，他终于站起来面对那些拥有黑猩猩、雀鸟和海豚的有脊骨动物的权威，并让他们听。既然无脊椎动物科学家已经看到了柱状图是如何堆积在他们身上的，他们就不想在那里结束。就像会议上的这个人开始在每次演讲时数观众人数，寻找优先待遇的模式。
So he'd gone to different talks and noted down how many people were sitting in the audience. And he was like, I only went to six talks today so it's not a huge sample size because I got real tired. But it looked to me like in the vertebrate talks there were more people watching. He sent me a photo of his notebook. So he just like took a screenshot with his phone of his notebook where he'd handwritten this and then emailed it to me, which was hilarious.
所以他去参加了不同的演讲，记下了观众席里坐着多少人。他说：“我今天只参加了六次演讲，所以样本量不大，因为我真的很累。”但对我来说，在脊椎动物演讲中，观众人数更多。他发给我一张他笔记本的照片。所以他只是用他的手机截屏了他的笔记本，上面是他手写的这个，然后通过电子邮件发给了我，太搞笑了。
All this felt great at first, but as Malcolm moved through the conference his scientist's brain noticed another pattern.
这一切起初感觉很好，但当马尔科姆穿过会议时，他的科学家大脑注意到了另一个模式。
We slowly started to realize that every single person who came up to start a conversation with me because they had been at that talk worked with an insect or with a spider or was an invertebrate researcher.
我们慢慢开始意识到，每一个上来找我聊天因为他们参加了那个演讲的人，都研究昆虫或蜘蛛，或者是无脊椎动物研究人员。
Which led him to this unwelcome conclusion.
这导致了他这个不受欢迎的结论。
The bird and mammal people, they weren't at that talk. I had been terrified and nervous to stand up and speak truth to power, so to speak, in this kind of like very marginal way. And then it was like discovering that power had just decided not even to show up that day. And everyone who came up to me-- the thing people would say was, oh my god, all the things I thought seem to be true, which is nice. But not as nice as, I'd never thought about this before and you really changed the way I think about the way our field is working.
鸟类和哺乳动物研究者，他们没在那次演讲中。我之前很恐惧、很紧张去站起来说话，对所谓的权力说真话，以这种非常边缘的方式。然后感觉就像发现权力那天甚至决定不出面。而每一个上来找我的人——人们会说的是：“噢，天哪，我所想的一切似乎都是真的。”这很好。但不如这个：“在此之前我从未想过这一点，你真的改变了我对我们领域运作方式的看法。”
Malcolm finally got his findings in front of the people who skipped his talk, the vertebrate majority, when he submitted his research for publication.
马尔科姆最终在他提交研究以供发表时，将他的发现展示在了那些错过他演讲的人——脊椎动物多数派——面前。
OK, yeah, the title of the paper is Taxonomic Bias in Animal Behaviour Publications. Evidence suggests that certain taxonomic groups are more thoroughly studied than others.
好的，是的，这篇论文的标题是《动物行为出版物中的分类偏见。证据表明某些分类组比其他分类组被更彻底地研究》。
The way scientific journals usually work is that when they consider a paper, they send it out for peer review. Basically, they get a bunch of other scientists in the field to look at it. It's all anonymous. When Malcolm gets back his peer reviews, they're unlike any he's gotten in the past. For one thing, they're twice the number of reviewers-- four when you usually get two. What's their response like?
科学期刊通常运作的方式是，当他们考虑一篇论文时，他们将其发送给同行评审。基本上，他们找该领域的其他科学家来看看。这一切都是匿名的。当马尔科姆拿回他的同行评审时，它们与他过去得到的任何评审都不同。首先，评审员数量是平时的两倍——当你通常得到两个时，他得到四个。他们的反应是什么样的？
The response was mixed, I guess, would be one way to put it. But mixed maybe doesn't explain how intense the extremes of the mixture were.
反应是混合的，我想这会是一种说法。但混合也许不能解释这种混合的极端有多强烈。
Because some people were very into it and some people were very not into it?
因为有些人非常喜欢它，而有些人非常不喜欢它？
Yeah. And the degree that people were into it was very high and the degree that people were not into it was also very high. Yeah, people were angry.
是的。人们喜欢它的程度非常高，人们不喜欢它的程度也非常高。是的，人们很生气。
And they went to a place he did not anticipate. I ask him to read me one of the negative reviews.
而且他们进入了一个他没预料到的地方。我请他读给我听其中一份负面评审。
Ugh "The solution advocated by the authors of this study is affirmative action by journal editorial boards to promote and highlight work on underrepresented taxa. Taken to the extreme this could lead to some kind of quota system policed by officers of taxonomic diversity on funding panels and journal editorial boards, and perhaps also on promotion and tenure committees," which is just outrageous. I'm getting all steamed just reading this again. Ugh.
呃。“本研究的作者所倡导的解决方案是期刊编辑委员会采取平权行动，以促进和突出关于代表性不足分类群的工作。走极端的话，这可能导致某种配额制，由资金小组和期刊编辑委员会的分类多样性官员进行监管，也许还有晋升和终身任职委员会。”这简直是令人发指的。我再次读到这些，感到火冒三丈。呃。
I don't know. I mean, the idea that we were proposing a quota system is crazy and it also kind of just means that they didn't read the paper. It means they got mad. They read part of the paper, got mad, and then didn't read the rest. I mean, honestly it does remind me of the conversations around affirmative action. It sounds very similar.
我不知道。我的意思是，我们提出配额制的想法很疯狂，而且也某种程度上意味着他们没读论文。这意味着他们生气了。他们读了论文的一部分，生气了，然后没读其余部分。我的意思是，老实说它确实让我想起了关于平权行动的对话。听起来非常相似。
They go there very quickly.
他们很快就进入了那个话题。
I know. We were just pointing out that it is a problem and that we need to think about how to solve that problem, and that may be assisting people who might be struggling working in underrepresented research groups might be something that we could do. I guess maybe that's affirmative action. I don't think it is, though.
我知道。我们只是指出这是一个问题，我们需要考虑如何解决这个问题，协助那些在代表性不足研究小组中可能挣扎的人也许是我们能做的事情。我猜也许那是平权行动。不过我不觉得是。
It was weird. The words were so similar. One, I just loved that they were like, the assumption that affirmative action is bad, which, cool. And then two, they immediately are just like, we bird people are under-- if we do this, bird people will be under attack. Like the way that people would be like, we only take the papers that are the best, and the bird ones happen to be the best.
这很奇怪。词汇太相似了。其一，我只是喜欢他们那样说，假设平权行动是坏事，这很酷。然后其二，他们立刻就像：“我们鸟类研究者被……”如果做这个，鸟类研究者将会受到攻击。就像人们会说：“我们只采取最好的论文，而鸟类论文恰好是最好的。”
And it's like, that was so similar to hearing about like, we just happen to take the best candidates. They're all white and dudes, but that doesn't mean anything. It's like, really? Does that not mean anything? Yeah. I was like, you can't even-- even here, in like, even in this very, very, very tiny scale thing, we can't even talk a little bit about how we might be a little bit biased about anything.
就像，那听起来与听到“我们只是碰巧采取了最好的候选人。他们全是白人和男性，但这并不意味着什么”太相似了。就像，真的吗？那并不意味着什么？是的。我就说，你甚至不能——即使在这里，在像这样非常、非常、非常小规模的事情上，我们也甚至不能稍微谈谈我们可能在任何事情上有点偏见。
Jackie, by the way, is Filipino and Chinese, and Malcolm?
顺便说一句，杰基是菲律宾和中国血统，而马尔科姆？
The opposite-- white. White is too bland, very white.
相反——白人。白人太平淡了，非常白。
I mean, it sounds like there's some kind of an element with her, just like, ah well, yeah, you know, now you know how it feels.
我的意思是，听起来她有点像是，“啊，好吧，是的，你知道，现在你知道感觉如何了。”
For sure. I definitely approached this with the energy of a person who has never had to fight any of these fights before.
当然。我绝对是以一个从未不得不打任何这些架的人的能量接近这件事的。
Not so for Jackie.
杰基则不然。
It was just like replaying so many dumb conversations, but it's like birds. And then I mentioned that sometimes I didn't want to talk about it. I would be like, OK, do you mind if we maybe not talk about the paper today, or whatever, because I've had this conversation a lot. And I'm tired of talking about it.
就像在重演这么多愚蠢的对话，但就像是鸟类。然后我提到有时我不想谈论它。我会说：“好的，你介意我们也许今天不谈论文，或什么的吗？因为我谈过很多次这些对话。而且我厌倦谈论它。”
She felt like, I know how this is going to end. But her exhaustion with the subject did not deter Malcolm. He was fired up, like they were on the verge of a revolution and it was time to lead the resistance for the ignored creatures of the world-- the boneless, the slimy, the microscopic.
她觉得就像，“我知道这会怎么结束。”但她对主题的精疲力竭并没有阻挡马尔科姆。他很激动，就像他们处于革命的边缘，是时候为世界上被忽视的生物领导抵抗了——无骨的、粘糊糊的、微观的。
Like, the iron is hot. We've got the editorial staff at Animal Behaviour thinking about this. This is the time to strike.
就像，铁很烫。我们有《动物行为》的编辑人员在思考这一点。这是罢工的时候了。
And it seemed like it was working. The powers that be, a.k.a. the journal, a.k.a. Animal Behaviour, accepted the paper and they got behind it. Later that year, one of the scientific organizations that publishes the journal, they asked Malcolm to do something big about this for their conference. He and two colleagues organized a special symposium. They flew in invertebrate scientists from around the world to come show off their bad ass research on their bad ass species-- parasitic larvae controlling and bursting out of their hosts, extreme mating weaponry in the New Zealand giraffe weevil.
而且看起来它奏效了。权威机构，也就是该期刊，也就是《动物行为》，接受了这篇论文，他们支持它。那年晚些时候，出版该期刊的科学组织之一，要求马尔科姆为他们的会议做一些关于这一点的大事。他和两位同事组织了一个特别座谈会。他们从世界各地飞来无脊椎动物科学家，来展示他们关于坏蛋物种的坏蛋研究——控制宿主并从宿主中爆发出来的寄生幼虫，新西兰长颈象鼻虫的极端交配武器。
The plan was to end the symposium with this big two part conversation. First, how does this bias limit what humans know about the animal world? And second, what should we do about it? Let's brainstorm solutions.
计划是以这种大型两部分对话结束座谈会。第一，这种偏见如何限制人类对动物世界的了解？第二，我们应该对此做什么？让我们头脑风暴解决方案。
It was a big deal. It's exactly what Malcolm had wanted. But when it came time to start the big two part conversation, they began by asking the audience, who here works with vertebrates? Raise your hands.
这是件大事。这正是马尔科姆想要的。但当开始大型两部分对话时，他们先问观众：“谁在这里研究脊椎动物？举手。”
And no one there did. Again, it was like the people we were hoping to talk to had just chosen not to show up for our symposium.
那里没有人举手。又一次，感觉就像我们希望谈话的人刚才选择不出现在我们的座谈会上。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
You know, like other symposiums were more exciting and ours was kind of underwhelming to people. The people who were actually in the positions to do things had apparently thought there were better things to do than be there.
你知道，就像其他座谈会更令人兴奋，我们的对人们来说有点平淡。那些真正处于做事位置的人显然认为有比在那里更好的事情可做。
Malcolm said that even some of his own friends, his bird friends, also skipped the symposium. It's a conference. There was another cool panel at the same time about animal cognition, which is almost exclusively vertebrates with researchers who study like hyenas and nightingales and all kinds of passerines. After that, nothing else really happened.
马尔科姆说，甚至他的一些朋友，他的鸟类朋友，也错过了座谈会。这是一个会议。同时有另一个关于动物认知的酷小组，几乎完全是研究鬣狗和夜莺以及各种雀形目鸟类的研究者。在那之后，没有其他真正发生的事情。
It occurs to me, too, that I feel like you learned this thing that a lot of people learn when they're trying to talk about diversity and have to point out something awkward, which is just like, it quickly gets turned into a panel discussion and sanitized and becomes this awkward conversation that doesn't go very well. And then in the end, nothing really changes.
我也想到，我感觉你学到了很多人们在试图谈论多样性且不得不指出某种尴尬事情时学到的东西，这只是就像，它很快变成了小组讨论，并被消毒，变成了这种进行得不太好的尴尬对话。然后最后，什么也没有真正改变。
Yeah, that's the perfect summary. That's exactly what happened.
是的，那是完美的总结。这正是发生的事情。
Oh, man. Have you seen any concrete changes at all?
噢，天哪。你有看到任何具体的改变吗？
No. None that I can think of. No, not really.
不。没有任何我想到的。不，没有真的。
One of the reasons we study animals is to learn about humans. Malcolm doesn't think that that should be the main goal. Nonetheless, studying the way that we study animals did teach him a lot about humans.
我们研究动物的原因之一是了解人类。马尔科姆不认为那应该是主要目标。尽管如此，研究我们研究动物的方式确实让他对人类学到了很多。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld and Miki Meek. People who put today's show together includes Bim Adewunmi, Emanuele Berry, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Hilary Elkins Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们节目今天由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德和米奇·米克制作。今天节目集合在一起的人包括比姆·阿德温米、伊曼纽尔·贝里、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、尼尔·德拉明、希拉里·埃尔金斯、达米安·格拉夫、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的主编是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks today to Gary Gullman, Nathan Englander, Lauren Weisstein, Anny Celsi, Kevin Allison, all the people we phoned about the spines they were growing, Yannos and Ashley Misitzis, Dai Shizuka, Wesley Hochachka, and Alexa Junge. Our website, Thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to her archive of over 650 episodes for absolutely free. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, last Halloween he draped a bed sheet over himself and chased his little nephew around yelling, boo! Boo! I swear, he scared the hell out of that little kid.
今天特别感谢加里·古尔曼、内森·英格兰德、劳伦·韦斯斯坦、安妮·塞尔西、凯文·艾利森，所有我们打电话询问他们正在长出的脊骨的人们、扬诺斯和阿什利·米西齐斯、戴·静香、卫斯理·霍查奇卡和亚历克莎·琼格。我们的网站，Thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听她超过650集的档案。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，去年万圣节他把自己裹在床单里，在屋里追着他的小侄子尖叫：“嘘！嘘！”我发誓，他把那个小孩吓坏了。
I feel really bad about it. He was a great guy, he did nothing wrong. A great guy and I feel bad for ghosting him.
我对此感到非常内疚。他是个好人，他没做错什么。他是个好人，我为对他玩消失感到难过。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。